husband has another job interview
tomorrow yeah hopefully that won't work
and how much did you want alone today
three okay this customer is here to take
out a three hundred dollar cash loan the
fee over two weeks is $48
three hundred we are gonna go over the
loan agreement real quick gonna be 348
thirty-one do if you annualize the cost
of the loan it works out to an interest
rate of four hundred and eighteen
percent that has TV news anchors piping
man they've been charging upwards of a
thousand thousand one hundred percent
price gouging is it's not five for 10 or
even 15 percent it's more like four
hundred and sixty percent fifteen
hundred dollars in interest eight
hundred percent interest is legal
it's a dangerous financial product these
are people who are living on the
economic margins journalist Gary Rivlin
is the author of broke USA how the
working poor became big business and you
see all kinds of people falling into
traps enter President Obama and the
Frank Dodd financial reform bill now the
federal government has the power to do
what six states and the District of
Columbia have already done regulate the
payday loan industry out of business
these reforms represent the strongest
consumer financial protections in
history in history where people know how
to be poor
better than middle class people and
certainly better than Washington
bureaucrats Todd Sawicki is a law
professor at George Mason University if
your transmission breaks and you need
$400 for car repair you need $400
whether or not you've got in the bank or
you don't
a 2007 Federal Reserve study found that
when Georgia regulated the payday
industry out of the state
consumers bounced more checks and filed
for bankruptcy at a higher rate simply
wishing away the world of broken
transmissions is it going to help people
will the people who are currently going
to pay day lenders now will they be
better off when if payday lending goes
away I think extending high price credit
to people living on the economic margins
who are barely getting by I see that as
making their lives harder
did you ever go
so deep into debt that you couldn't get
out or usual yeah
I'd fallen I think ten thousand twelve
thousand dollars in credit card debt
would it be better if you hadn't been
extended the credit card debt in the
first place I know I I you know I had to
pay my rent so I mean I had to buy food
it wasn't like I'm a pretty frugal guy
it's not like I lost my head and bought
flat-screen TVs as long as there has
been consumer credit there have been
people who have been very upset that
other people they believe are not using
consumer credit responsibly and when we
start trying to tell people how they
should float their bills in order to
keep their electricity from being turned
off that's not going to end up helping
them critics of the industry tend to
focus on the cost of a payday loan so
you're making three or four times the
profit margin off the single mom with
two kids making twenty grand a year as
you are off the white collar more
prosperous banking customer that to me
is one of the moral problems with a
payday loan but payday loan profits turn
out to be fairly average once you factor
in the cost of maintaining stores and
writing off bad loans a 2007 study found
that payday companies generally see
returns of only 10% a year which is
comparable to the profits of other
financial service firms the operating
margin for Advance America last quarter
was nine point seven six percent if
they're making less profit does I make
them less immoral I I'd rather look at
rather than the morality of this is this
a healthy product is this a financial
product that makes sense for people is
this a product that needs to be further
regulated regulation of consumer credit
interferes with the contract that
borrowers and lenders want to enter into
that doesn't mean they won't enter into
a contract it just means they'll enter
into a contract on terms probably
inferior to the ones that they preferred
hey earnest this is Greg the owner and
talent financial services the customer
is treated with dignity and respect
let me give my card
thank you letter no say to you I have to
transact business so that we are the
destination of choice yeah and I'll be
here the next three days myself so you
got nothing to worry about
we don't look down our nose at them I'll
see what I can do for you
okay thank you you're welcome - opening
a new consumer watchdog with just one
job looking out for people as they
interact with the financial system the
impact of the massive financial
regulatory reform bill will be to
increase the cost of credit reduce its
availability
the real question we have now is will
the bureau and the increasing cost a lot
or increasing it a little